yeah how do you feel about uh because
obviously Chicago has is probably
man Chicago if we just think about like
the history of hip-hop that's come out
of Chicago it's very diverse it's vast I
mean in my opinion yeah you know Kanye's
probably the got the best discography
ever and then you got like the new
which is like you know obviously
shout out to Dirk and those guys Polo G
everybody but like uh yeah is there
anybody in Chicago that you're you're
checking for that maybe we haven't heard
of yet
ah that's a great question you know we
have a few singers that are really doing
that thing
um John Doe is dope
um there's a singer Santa Emery
um
but you know what we really had our our
big run in like 2012 when Keith and yeah
we're going crazy it was it was just
different for all of us
um
but yeah Chicago We're very talented I
think we get a lot of flat because like
the violence and or like you know
just because our nature
but yeah I mean listen a lot I mean you
know that is that there is something to
be said that well yeah Chicago's they go
straight to you know the shootings and
killings yeah
um sometimes I think that over overrides
like you know The Talented we got
going also just the city in general
because like I know it's not like like I
think when a lot of people think of
Chicago they think it's like
bad everywhere and it's like a great
City it's a great city
um and then on top of that though like
you know people coming out of Chicago we
aren't evil people or you know we got
great you know we do great things in the
city as well how do you deal with like
nine degree weather I'm just curious
like what do you do do you just stay
inside yeah okay we got like you have to
layer up I can't tell you how many coats
and scarves and like that I have
it's crazy would you like I I just
wouldn't leave I'm Eric I'm Uber eating
everything exactly Uber Eats deliver
everything
no but for me though I think um you know
we're used to it like we grew up in and
we walked to school in the cold like
that so Jesus I guess it's like
accustomed to it now yeah